my channel is sponsored by keeps which
means we will hear more from them
somewhere in the middle of this video
hello everyone i'm alana welcome to my
channel where we do two q a's a month
this one is a gaming q a the next one
will be a personal q a you can leave
questions regarding either of them and i
will just pull them into the right video
for the next one first question is from
jd's quiz who said hey aladdin hi jd i'm
probably too late but i was wondering if
you've had time to read the new york
times article about elden ring and if we
could get your thoughts
no you asking me this question was what
actually prompted me to record this
right now and to publish it today
because i was like oh i do try to do
these in the first half of the month
here we go new york times eldon ring i
have not read whatever this is so let's
do it live shall we in elden ring the
struggle feels real looks like this
article was published today and is
listed under tech fixed that's
interesting
do they not have a gaming section on new
york times well business politics us
sports health and why opinion tech
science wow they don't
oh they have art i wonder if they
usually like put them into pop culture i
can't imagine the new york times does a
ton of consistent gaming coverage based
on the lack of category in any case the
video game evokes the hardship and
disappointment of the pandemic but also
the hope of human communion okay fair
yeah in the last two years the pandemic
has brought us many works of art that
have tried to definitively capture
humanity's struggle there was that movie
with leonardo dicaprio turning pink as
he shouts it okay whatever
get to the point no medium has come as
close to perfectly encapsulating our
situation as video games in the
beginning when many of us were in
lockdown and baking mediocre sourdough
we did not get on that red grace we
played animal crossing that i did do 600
hours which involves finding confidence
simple tasks like fishing and gardening
while stranded on an island this year we
are playing elden ring a ruthlessly
difficult game that only gets harder the
more you play it fundamentally disagree
with that that about sums up what it's
been like to live in a pandemic also
fundamentally disagree with that i think
it's easier now than it was in 2020
before people were even vaccinated and
we thought that we weren't allowed to
like touch packages eldering is a story
that has something to do with a ring but
more important is its design it's an
open world game meaning you can do
whatever whenever you want players to
ride a horse through a poison swamp
sprint across malt and lava blah blah no
matter what you choose to do you'll
probably die again and again trying to
do it sometimes for hours that's because
the slightest mis-timing of a button
press will make you fall to your death
or open you to attack even the most
experienced gamers would die dozens of
times in a dungeon before reaching the
boss the main villain at the end of a
game level okay so this makes me think
that
this is uh written for people who don't
play video games in mind probably also i
should mention the reason that i was so
willing to answer this question is that
i kept seeing people like vaguely tweet
about this article on twitter in a way
that seems negative so i i will admit
that i am coming in with bias where i'm
like curious to find whatever the
negativity is that people are reacting
to it from but i don't know what any of
that actually is context though none of
this makes elden ring sound like a crowd
pleaser but the video game a
collaboration between the creative
director hidetaka miyazaki and the game
of thrones author george r martin is on
track to become the best seller of the
year with 12 million copies sold within
a month of its release in february it's
so successful it's nuts eldering has
done so well at some point in the game
you face a dragon you have a choice to
fight or flee at first you probably
retreat and eventually after acquiring
enough strength and the proper weapon or
magic spell
okay yeah sure it's difficult to imagine
eldering having this sort of cultural
cachet in any other era in year three of
the pandemic as vaccination rates have
risen and hospitalization cases have
dipped in some areas offices schools and
restaurants have reopened to many
americans the dragon has been slain yet
in other parts of the world and you vary
into the coronavirus is driving another
way of any new york cases are beginning
to climb again some of us let our guard
down to have some semblance of normal
life we are bracing ourselves for that
stupid bird around the corner that might
still kill us our hard-learned lesson of
the pandemic to expect disappointment
and more struggle
has trained us well for elden ring
so what is this what is this footage
is this like somebody
recorded that screen
they did this is for sure somebody
recorded their screen look at the little
black bar and like the weird
okay
okay new york times
where the dicaprio movie don't look up
which i've still not seen was polarizing
because it picked a side that criticized
anyone in denial of the apocalypse elden
rings choose your own eventual man is
more inclusive for a populist that can't
seem to agree on anything in eldering
there is no right or wrong technically
but the community would disagree with
you on that to defeat a boss okay so
essentially what this article is
okay i'm really close to being done
let's get through it to the fetal boss
you can carefully study its move and
plan an attack or you can cheese it with
a cheap trick that requires no skill and
ensures victory either way a win is a
win such a flexible game may resonate
with players worldwide and bring them
together in a time when people are
choosing their own truths about masks
shots and information they read online
in general players mostly suffer through
elden ring alone but there are parts so
difficult like an ultra tough boss fight
that people will need to get help from
others online again
this is totally
written for a non-gaming audience i
think
to accommodate this the game wrecks
small statues in challenging areas that
act as summoning posts to bring in a
co-operator once the mission is complete
the good samaritan disappeared
struggle has always been a central theme
in the games of mr miyazaki who
mr
miyazaki who's rose to fame with the
modest success of the dark souls trilogy
elden rings predecessors but so is the
need for people to turn to one another
um
i mean that's sort of true
however the this is the actual reason
that
eldon ring is successful is that it's
off the back of several
previously successful fromsoft games
that even if you didn't play them or buy
them you knew what they were so this is
just
coming off of that
this isn't um
i don't think eldering is at all
successful because of the pandemic it is
time to talk about keeps keeps is a
subscription service that helps men keep
their hair i have a number of male
friends who use it and really like it
which is why i've always been on board
with working with keeps there are so
many products for women's insecurities
that i feel like we should talk about
some options for men who are interested
too of course there's no shame in being
bold in fact two out of three guys will
experience hair loss by the time they're
35 but if this is something that you're
concerned about you can get on board
with keeps and the earlier that you take
action the more hair you'll keep keeps
offers clinically proven treatments to
combat the symptoms of hair loss all
treatment plans are personalized and
doctor recommended as well as affordable
typically half the cost of pharmacy
prices treatments are also delivered
straight to your door one thing i
particularly love about keeps is that it
has a network of expert medical advisors
prescribers and care specialists to
support you in making your hair goals a
reality so while you're getting your
daily supply of treatment every three
months at half the cost of a pharmacy
you also have 24 7 care and support each
treatment plan comes with a full year of
unlimited messaging so you can connect
with your prescribing doctor about
anything anytime so whether you're
looking to prevent hair loss stimulate
hair growth or just take better care of
the hair you have keeps has you covered
in addition to in addition to clinically
proven treatments keeps has an
award-winning all-natural thickening
shampoo and conditioner system and keeps
physicians will help you highlight the
right products and treatments for your
specific condition and hair goals
hairless stops with geeps to get 50 off
your first order go to keeps.com alana
pierce or just click the link in the
description that's k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash alana pierce mr miyazaki it's so
weird
who didn't respond to requests for
comment had said in interviews
that he was inspired by personal
experience many years ago when he was
driving up a snow-covered hill that is
true the cars behind him were pushing
him and that's how he decided he wanted
to have
dark souls multiplayer this is another
just somebody recording their tv kelsey
mcclellan
does nobody at new york times have a
capture card i guess not
i mean this person did their best
clearly what happened to that part why
did it scoot over so far like that was
pretty well scented and then there was
something that happened and it just kind
of
moved all the way over
it almost looks like this was done on a
tripod
that's how hard you tried to do this
very strange okay we come into each
other's lives for a minute and disappear
and still make an impact said kezza
mcdonald who is a friend because it's
great
the video games editor for the guardian
and author of you died a book about
miyazaki's games
it's not really one player versus the
game it's the entire community of
players versus the game i generally
agree with that i like that take
nice work kaza also still mr miyazaki
just call him miyazaki or miyazaki son
mr miyazaki i don't i can't it's very
strange
by the time i had finished elden ring
with some help from friends and
strangers online over about five weeks i
didn't come out of the game feeling more
anxious or pessimistic i ended up making
plans with friends i hadn't seen in two
years many of us have endured the
pandemic alone because restrictions and
health risks make it difficult to travel
and gather indoors it has been an
impossible situation to navigate and the
struggle goes on but we're in this
together for the long haul why not turn
to one another that's it
okay so
um in my opinion this article is nothing
i don't think this is at all
worth the um
i don't know passive aggressive
sub tweets i've been seeing on twitter
and i also know that uh
sometimes
journalists have an amount of features
that they have to write like you can be
assigned to write a feature a week and
if you don't have an opinion on anything
that can be really difficult to do so
you're just like [ __ ] it i don't
i don't know i have to say something
about anything
and so you could just be sitting there
and you would go hmm you know this
pandemic
an elden ring just kind of give me
similar feelings when i get all
introverted about it
maybe i should write something about
that because i have a quota this article
is nothing it is not saying anything
other than the author had an opinion or
like a mild feeling i don't know he's
just making like a cute
correlation you know
and i feel like
all the time mainstream media which i
would consider the new york times to be
talks about a video game in a way that
like most gamers feel is inaccurate or
you know out of touch and not
representing the larger video game
community accurately every time
i just want to be like listen y'all
somebody's played video games my whole
life and works in the games industry who
cares like this article is not hurting
anybody sometimes
just let them write it
okay you know why why did this get so
much traction i have i have very little
opinion other than that this article was
just somebody talking about their
personal experience in a way that i
found to be uninteresting and not
particularly relatable it didn't feel
like it was like [ __ ] on elden ring
it seems like the point of it is more in
the sense which is our hard learned
lesson of the pandemic to expect
disappointment and more struggle has
trained us well for elden ring
it's it's who cares who cares
whatever it's so inconsequential and
just i just think this article is boring
more than anything and i love talking
about you know things people have
written that way i'm sure this means
something to brian who wrote it
um
and to other people but to me whatever
man you know whatever i think it's silly
i also think it's fine
that's the hot take
i'm sorry that i don't have spice your
opinion sometimes people call me a fence
sitter in reality i feel like i'm just
rational
take it or leave it
i just don't feel like i care about a
lot of [ __ ]
if if it is of no consequence ricky
rich93 said hey lana can you comment any
further on the reasons behind why
platinumgame's scalebound was cancelled
yeah so i had heard like a bunch of
different stories about this that i
think i touched on a while ago i was
gonna make a full video about it but the
problem is that i don't believe any of
them 100 and i've heard conflicting
stories the one that i heard the most
often about why scalebound was cancelled
was that the engine couldn't handle it
and that other games at the same time
had also been cancelled
that were open world dead island 2
running on the same tech
tech couldn't handle it and apparently
xbox at the time wanted to make sure
that they had a portfolio of games using
a variety of different engines
scalebound was supposed to run on unreal
by microsoft's request supposedly
platinum couldn't make it happen so yeah
it was microsoft wanted a portfolio of
specific engines platinum was unfamiliar
with the engine and multiple games at
that point in time were having trouble
getting an open world to function
on unreal there are some other stories
that i heard that is the main one and
the one that i had heard from people
you know very closely associated with
the project multiple times but i had
also heard some others that um are much
more i don't know dramatic that i don't
want to share just because i feel like i
could probably get in legal trouble for
sharing not at all confident in them
being founded and they pertain to like
personal relationships and i just like
don't feel like i should uh
because they could be total nonsense and
they are
potentially damaging to certain people
so i don't i don't really want to i
think you're pretty safe to assume that
microsoft wanting the game to be on
unreal and platinum not having any idea
how to use unreal how to make
an open world unreal game
probably a pretty safe bet we
actually don't have too many more gaming
questions so i think i will leave it
there this time
oh except for man any word on beyond
good and evil
no where is beyond good and evil too i
actually played it you know ages ago i
played like obviously a tech demo i
didn't know that i was gonna love what
they were gonna come out with but that
that's one of those games it feels like
it's like disappeared that's nuts i have
no idea where that is hopefully we'll
find out soon but yes that is it for me
today everybody thank you for watching
the q a you can leave comments on
questions in the comments for the next
one
my parents will actually be in town when
the next one goes up so i probably won't
have a ton of uploads for the rest of
the month i'll be in boston for pax next
week if you want to come say hi i'm
doing the keynote presentation so i will
potentially see some of you there which
is exciting and otherwise
yeah not a ton of uploads this month
just because i'm prioritizing family
time and i'm very excited thank you all
for watching thank you to keeps for
sponsoring this video
i will see you guys next time bye